what makes someone laugh
that's a physiological response
some people some people think some
scientists think that what happens is
is your your brain is full of neurons
and the neurons have created neural
pathways and so the neural Pathways that
they've created help you go from if I
ask you uh what's what's your street
address you tell me because that's a
neural pathway so when when you uh or
when somebody says I dropped something
the neural pathway says uh either I'll
I'll pick it up or not my problem you
you pick it up that's you know that's a
neural pathway
when when you hear a joke the joke is is
kind of fooling the neural pathway that
it's going to go down the same pathway
and then it it it kind of creates a
different neural pathway which because
the brain is based on electricity
um and I'm as you can tell I'm not a
scientist uh but uh what happens is is
there's there's kind of uh almost an
explosion that happens in the brain
because it it has to you know all of a
sudden change gears change directions
it's literally creating a new neural
pathway in the brain and that creates uh
kind of a
physiological response where your air is
being brought up and and it it comes out
and comes out in laughter uh we see this
in babies we see this in chimpanzees
this response where something is
surprising but not dangerous
um uh and uh and so and so laughter can
can create it can be created but it's
based upon the fact that somebody has
said something that
is surprising yet in retrospect
inevitable if it's surprising but makes
no sense you just kind of go huh
if it's not surprising
then you're just going to go okay
so it needs so if you're creating a
moment that's both
surprising yet in retrospect inevitable
um
uh that creates that can create laughter
and then go ask a neuroscientist
that's the next Ted Talk yeah that's the
next step
how important is it to make yourself
laugh
well if you have to make yourself laugh
uh I think uh you know you know take two
aspirin and see a doctor in the morning
um
I think I think it's important that you
that you seek out things that will lift
your spirit
uh for many people it's it's something
funny it's something it's laughter but
you know some people like
like yoga
um you know like uh like meditation but
but I think that uh it's I think it's
important to
see the world from a different
perspective and that's that's partly
what comedy does it it helps you see
your life
uh from a slightly different perspective
if you're if you're watching Die Hard
that's a lot of fun it's exciting you
can live vicariously through somebody
who who's Daring Do you could probably
never duplicate uh but how close is that
to your own life
but if you're if you're um
watching party down
about a group of uh uh servers in a
catering company
well maybe uh maybe you don't work in a
catering company but you work somewhere
is similar or the office or Parks and
Rec something there that is similar to
you and and and has you see your own
life again because it's about
identifying it as you see your own life
from a slightly different perspective
unless it's too close to your own life
and then you're crying because that's
true that's your reality that's true
maybe when it's too close well if you're
if you're already if you're already a
server don't watch party down then watch
hacks okay I mean you know because
sometimes when you when you're you're
talking about the fish that's in the
world of the water you know in the water
they don't know that they're in this
world the imaginary world and so
sometimes when a world is uh like when I
saw this as 40 to me it was hilarious it
was sort of this La couple living this
sort of Bourgeois life and it's not
exactly my life but I'm able to laugh at
it because it's not so close to mine but
if it was more my life I think it would
be a little more uh probably less
laughter but uh well I'm not sure I mean
so which which which fictional
Counterpoint is closest to you The
Honeymooners
um oh you know Roseanne or the Connors
um maybe not that one but and I did love
that show by the way I love that one so
maybe that's why um but uh uh yeah I
think maybe you have to have it a little
more removed if it's too close to your
own because I was wondering if you're
able to laugh at yourself are you that's
a very that's a very
uh rare Talent
how many people do you know can laugh at
themselves well maybe past selves not
current
maybe past cells because anything
current might be too right and that's
that's one of the things that comedy
helps us it helps it has us laugh at
ourselves
in you know
at one one step removed
so when we're laughing at
um uh
uh Gene Arthur and and Hannah Ein binder
um not Gene Arthur Gene Smart and Hannah
Ein binder in in hacks
um yeah I'm I'm not a stand-up comic but
I I I've been in that world I know that
world uh and uh and if I'm laughing
there I'm also healing myself
because some of the things that they've
gone through I've gone through and maybe
I haven't laughed about it but this this
helps me see that through that
perspective so so in that way a comedy
is um is just as good as therapy and and
less expensive right and no one's taking
notes well hopefully not well one of the
things that's great about comedy
especially contemporary comedy
um is that it it no longer avoids uh
the the the fact that we all change
when when the radio sitcoms trans
translated or or trans
um transformed into television sitcoms
the formula was
a a central character
who had a good sense of humor
um would solve a solvable problem
in 22 minutes
by interacting with a small group of
characters
and and everything stayed the same
so that any one episode of of a sitcom
is viewable because any other episode of
the sitcom uh was basically the same
Dynamics and that was okay but what's
changed because of cable because of
streaming just because of people's
tastes
um
is that
what you see now is that character since
it comes all change
it's all about transformation so it used
to be that only a character in in a in a
long-form narrative in a film
would change you know Bill Murray in
Groundhog Day from the beginning to the
end Scrooge which is not really funny
although it had some funny moments
um uh and and all and all the comic uh
takeoffs on the Christmas Carol and
Scrooge
um I think there's one with Ryan
Reynolds and Will Ferrell out now
um you know they come and they uh it
starts in one place and then they change
but now
um
uh
with uh hacks with Ted lasso
um uh somewhere someplace I think that's
the name of it it's uh this uh uh thing
that takes place in Oklahoma
reservation dogs uh they they're it's
all about change it's all about what
happens as we're changing what happens
to make us change what happens is we uh
as we resist change in in a way that
isn't just This Is Us
which by the way for those of you who
like this is us
that's okay I hated it if a writer is
having a script reading what cues will
they pick up on to know that the script
is no longer funny
the crickets
the silence
um
I I think it's important that if you're
having a script reading you record the
entire event because at a certain point
you won't be able to
listen or observe
objectively anymore and so record the
entire event because it'll surprise you
the things that you thought didn't go
well you'll hear
uh you might hear more response than you
thought there was because you know maybe
you were fixated on this didn't go well
or that didn't go well
or conversely uh if you thought
everything was swimmingly and then you
hear it back and you hear
the here's what happens with friends who
come to your readings yeah first minute
one through minute seven lots of
laughter but after seven minutes you
know you've if it's not happening if if
there's nothing alive happening uh the
laughter Peters out and then there's
always these one or two people who are
just they just love you
and so you'll uh actor will say a line
and
and it'll be it'll be a solo just just
just standing out and you know that's
just that's just pity laughter or that's
just supportive laughter but but you'll
the cues are
are people engaged
or are people not engaged if they're
engaged something that's something that
you wrote is working if they're not
engaged something you wrote is not
working and it's not the audience's
fault
it's not the people it's not the people
listening to the readings fall
um
you know it might be something that you
can easily fix or or maybe maybe there's
an outside reason that has nothing to do
with the script
but most writers who look for that
outside reason are avoiding their own
responsibility
for creating a
dramatic event a comedic dramatic event
that is engaging so here's the most
important thing rather than uh looking
for the you know the clues or the hints
of what's going well what's not going
well after the reading you want to ask
your audience
to tell you four things and and and just
what parts what parts were you engaged
in
what parts were you not engaged in
what characters did you want to see more
of
what characters did you not want to see
more of
where were you confused
and that's all that's all you need to
know don't ask for any don't ask for any
suggestions don't don't ask well what do
you think when she when she said this in
act in in the second part no no you
don't want suggestions Neil Gaiman is a
writer who once said that 95 of the
criticisms you receive are correct but
95 percent of the solutions you're
offered are incorrect meaning if
somebody doesn't like something that's
real a human being didn't respond to
what it was that is absolutely useful
information but why they didn't like it
what you should do about it
that you should throw out because it's
really about taking the your your own
EKG of the script
you don't want that EKG machine to say
well you know you should eat more fiber
no you just you know something
something's not going right and I gotta
figure it out myself
and it seems like if you invite people
that you know whether they're actors and
they're in the industry or not they're
going to have a similar sense of humor
and so then no okay do you have friends
that have an opposite sense of humor I
you know again senses of humor are are
variable they're they're uh everybody
has a different sense of humor so uh I
think somebody once said that that they
never heard Lauren Michaels laugh in an
audition
you know and that's a scary thing you're
there and the guy who you want to hire
you never responds and so that can make
you go crazy but everybody has their own
sense of humor their own
uh their own specific sense of criteria
that makes them laugh or not laugh but
you people are either engaged or not
engaged I mean you know are they
shifting around in their seats are they
um are they leaning forward
meaning what's gonna wonder what's gonna
happen next
um
so so when when you're when you're doing
a reading the important thing is
to uh don't spend a lot of don't spend a
lot of your time trying to rehearse the
readers you're just doing more damage
um you don't have enough time to do it
well and you have enough time to screw
things up so just give them the script
uh make sure that the stage directions
if any that are read out loud are
clearly delineated so people don't trip
over themselves
and make sure that you have an equal
number of listeners to the people who
are reading so that you get some sort of
a sense how things are going and serve
wine and cheese and wine
you know and and and more wine so that
so that people are in a receptive mode